Summary
This lecture's given you a flavour of some
advanced image processing operations, but
really only just touched on some of these
techniques. So if they've peaked your interested,
then I suggest you go off and do some additional
reading and experiment with some of the code
that's provided in the toolbox.
The first technique that we looked at was
mathematical morphology, but this time with
more complex structuring elements. So we talked
about how we can use morphological operations
to detect lines with a particular slope within
an image. We can actually create quite complex
structuring elements.
We also discussed an example where the structuring
element contained a circle and we used that
to reconstruct some missing parts of an object;
a tomato fruit, which we know is essentially
circular.
We looked very briefly at the hit and miss
transform. We can use that for operations
like skeletonization and finding the intersection
points of a number of line segments.
We introduced the Hough Transform, a well-known
technique of finding linear features within
an image. In order to use the Hough Transform,
we introduced an alternative parameterization
of lines.
It's not often known as the Polar Form of
a Line. Each line is described in terms of
the perimeter Theta and Rho. Each point that
lays on an edge of an image, votes for a large
number of lines. Those votes are tallied in
an accumulator array. The lines that receive
the largest number of votes then are dominant
lines in the scene; they are supported by
a large number of edge pixels and such lines
have been overlaid graphically on the image
of the church here.
Finally we talked about finding corresponding
points. It's very easy for you and me to find
the co-ordinate of this balcony corner in
two quite different pictures of that same
scene, but it's not so easy for a computer
algorithm to do that.
We also touched on the problem that we can't
just rely on the grey scale intensity of the
pixel to find it in the other scene.
In order to solve this problem we introduced
the notion of a Corner Detector, which says
something about the similarity of a region
of an image, to adjacent regions of the image.
We can boil this down to a very useful two
by two matrix called the Structure Tensor.
And that tells us a lot about the local shape
of the intensity surface of the image at this
particular point. We can use the Eigenvalues
of this matrix to determine whether this region
of the image is flat or constant, whether
it contains and edge or whether it contains
a peak.
The structure tensor is very easily computed
from the horizontal and vertical gradient
images smoothed with a Gaussian Kernel. These
are all techniques that we've met previously.
Two common corner detector algorithms then
use slightly different techniques to find
those points where both Eigenvalues are large.
Finally, we talked about feature matching.
Given that I had a set of corner points in
one image, a set of corner points in another
image, I take a region of pixels around each
of those interest points and look at the similarity
of those image regions to determine the correspondence
between points in the two images.